regarder la télévision sur une carte d
acier spécialement vendredi soir quand
le feuilleton quand même pas je regarde
un fait tous les regards de bien si ça
vous intéresse beaucoup
mais elle est allée un peu plus loin par
exemple le journal télévisé tels qu'ils
se déroulent est telle que vous l'avez
vu se dérouler depuis ce matin puisque
vous êtes depuis ce matin avec nous dans
la rivière c'est affolant
moi je suis malade je suis dans un état
pas du tout normal vous vivez comme com
com comme des dingues c'est affolant
je trouve plus mes mots croyez moi
j'étais venu avec un panier nos jeux ne
trouve plus rien parce que vous m'avez
rendu folle depuis ce matin il ça
commence à 9 heures du matin et vous
fait ça toute l'année
oui jours mais c'est terrible dans cet
internat scié non c'est un peu la grande
différence entre votre travail est le
nôtre c'est que vous normalement lorsque
vous fait de la comédie ou coup fait du
théâtre le cinéma c'est prévu tout est
noté l avance alors que nous les choses
changent sans arrêt bouger c'est là où
vous avez beaucoup de talent parce que
l'actualité qui tombe là d'une minute à
l'autre je trouve que c'est que vous
êtes des dix hommes est extraordinaire
mais moi je ne pourrais pas faire ce
métier d'enseignant notre pelouse du ray
pourvu que nos directeurs écoute
ah bah j'espère mais de m'envoyer
positive
voilà c'est ça une exposition à ce
moment à paris qui se tient d'ailleurs
jusqu'au 22 février prochain la porte de
versailles et qui s'appelle le salon
rétromobile mais je suis pour le taf a
un peu de muscle aux parisiens et aux
gens du du monde entier d'aller un peu à
bicyclette
on aurait pas de problème de pétrole
vous comprenez et je trouve que ça
serait formidable
il n'entre porterait mieux voilà
exactement moi ce que j'ai dit tu
proposes usi si vous voulez pourquoi on
reconnaît des éléments de réflexion
finalement de jeter un oeil sur le
reportage qui ont effectué pour nous
jean louis doucet et l'euro massardier
donc dans ce salon rétromobile situé à
la porte de versailles
parmi toutes les incongruités de ce
salon il ya un moba
modèle d'automobile tout à fait
particulier qui s'appelle l'économie
mobile un peu perdu au milieu de ses
grandes soeurs voici les cônes au mobile
cette voiture ou du moins si l'on peut
appeler ainsi cette monoplace à trois
roues de 150 centimètres cubes a réussi
l'exploit l'an dernier de faire très
exactement 12 167 km distance brest
monte carlo avec un litre d'essence
défis dont le constructeur tire des
normes pour équiper ses derniers modèles
et faire un peu oublier cette grosse
mercedes de 1939 cire ou 40 litres aux
cent la plupart des voitures exposées
ici sont à vendre
elles sont toutes en état de marche
beaucoup ont été entièrement restauré
leurs prix peuvent aller jusqu'à 350
mille francs pour cette packard de 1927
par exemple en ligne par les modèles des
années
il est très bon modèle sport et des
fabrications qui correspondent à des
périodes de ma jeunesse où j'ai été
évidemment fort intéressés par ces
modèles que je ne pouvais pas acquérir
parce que j'étais trop jeune ou parce
que ça aurait dépassé les moyens à
l'époque cette voiture a été restauré en
1981 est ce que nous perd pas un peu de
sa valeur historique seulement parce que
la voiture a été restaurée avec les
mêmes matériaux qui est empli à l'époque
et permettre son authenticité si on
avait mis par une jambe des ailes en
matière plastique ou des matériaux
modernes mais même la peinture tout et
de la même procédé d'époque de
fabrication pour restaurer cette porsche
1919 il a fallu 12 100 heures de travail
à 100 francs le calcul est simple mais
on peut quand même se passionner à
moindre frais en collectionnant aussi
les documentations automobile est ce
qu'il ya un secret pour être un bon
collectionneur wee aa pas de l'âme de
tout ramasser et rien jeter et tout ça
mais le vrai secret je dois avouer avec
un peu de confusion
c'est des célibataires célibataire sans
doute aussi pour pouvoir mieux confier
le lustrage en effet la main féminine
semble également doué pour la
carrosserie est ce que cette femme là ne
fait pas son ménage s'occupe de la
voiture vous disiez tout à l'heure vous
étiez pas très pour les automobiles il
ya quand même des deux villes très joli
il a des voitures c'est très joli oui
mais c'est plus de monde je ne retrouve
que c'est fini maintenant nous sommes à
une période tellement nous n'aurons
bientôt plus rien mais je trouve que il
faut prendre les devants s'il ya plus
d'eau chaude froide avant que ça
n'arrive et s'il ya plus de pétrole il
faut prendre une bicyclette
voilà il faut devancer les événements je
les dis en traçant votre portrait
brièvement tout à l'heure quand on a eu
une longue traversée du désert comme la
vôtre et qu'on revient alors quand on
était vraiment au top ce sommet une
grande star si de l'air c'est difficile
de voir dans votre tête peut-être mais
moi pendant la mienne ce difficile
chez soi et de voir les autres bon on
fait autre chose vous savez on essaie de
s'occuper à autre chose on réfléchit où
c'est
c'est à la fois on fait un retour en bas
je peux pas vous dire maintenant ça me
fait tout drôle
surtout que c'est une traversée du
désert à pied ils le peuvent pour
reprendre un terme aux examens étaient
d'ailleurs d'une crosse célèbre le
nostalgique plus que le que non nous on
savait la nostalgie la vie tout le monde
l'a l'acceptent c'est ainsi puis voilà
il faut être un peu raisonnable et non
j'ai pas d'aigreur pas du tout pas du
tout suicidaire et je pense que les
méthodes de travail ont changé à lhassa
où la tunique et d euros le mythe a
narré le mythe le laos et le marathon
toc toc pif paf pouf
ap on tire la combière avait pour moi la
première fois la deuxième moi je fais le
jeu wii suzy vous déjà mécontentes
alors je fais un bon c'est fini a rien à
dire très bien mais je me suis j'ai
plongé
c'est de la nostalgie vous exprimer au
nom mais la vie change et c'est normal
c'est il faut c'est à dire qu'il faut se
il faut se mettre au diapason en quoi
c'est comme ça que j'ai pas la nostalgie
disons que si j'avais peut-être 20 ans
j'aurais pas de
j'aurais pas été ahuri comme ça
maintenant ça va j'ai fait quatre mois
avec le mythomane
si on nous nous continuons les épisodes
croyez moi je sais
[Musique]